et bien bonjour les amis choix vous
allez bien jaune se retrouvent pour une
vidéo avec les deux zigotos surprise on
sait pas qui faisait des masques en fait
attention et déjà remercier le m
lemaitre à la règle qui dans la
précédente vidéo nous a vraiment porté
bonheur nous a apporté beaucoup de
choses déjà donné la force de diriger
les mots alors qui de nouveau vers la
lumière grâce à la force bon les mecs
vous savez comment ça se passe et tape
une pour la connais bien maintenant
alors engagé une idée d'un bit
alors ça fait un talent un tintin tintin
tintin tintin boîte à air et avec tout à
fait compris le message
allez bon allez je vais me débrouiller
avec ça voilà le moment là ça sent à
quel moment c'est parce que j'ai fait
quand j'ai chantonnay c'est grâce à qui
ça votre avis c'est grâce à qui colle à
ses pouvoirs étape 2 je dois je le
rappelle ne s'attend pas à battre cette
émission c'est toi qui me fait un stop
lagarde
il nous a que vous allez remarquer que
je vais toujours rien dans cette vidéo
au est-ce que je peux officiellement
musiciens on écoute les deux les uns sur
les autres
allez ne marchent bien déjà comme ça
elle est papa tu l'as déjà merci c'est
fini pour moi plus les gabon vis des
généraux voilà je vais chercher 3 et 2
[Musique]
et franchement il va finir pour faire un
album mais bientôt étape 4 les
fioritures et non pas la co feature ah
ok les mecs vous savez qu un saint
michel au japon pour aller chercher un
chien bref le mec tout ça pour dire que
j'aimerais qu'elle est petite des petits
instruments qui nous rappellent
finalement l'ambiance asiatique
l'ambiance japonaise un gros big up à
tous les asiatiques
ok owen franchement c'est lourd c'est
long beach à miami il est maintenant
temps de passer à l'étape préféré une de
la planète à savoir écouter l'instru
avec tous les sons bien
[Musique]
alors j'en profite pour vous dire que
vous pouvez voter pour nous pour les nrj
music awards vous êtes en train de faire
quoi la pub oui comme quoi y'a les nrj
music juste pendant que squeeze est pas
là il faut avouer que ça ne l'est pas ou
font actuellement on fait des vidéos
comme ça va lui mais en vrai c'est pas
du tout envie de nous ce qu'on voulait
c'est faire des vidéos avec cyprien mais
bon cyprien et a repris les cours je
vois ce plaisir peut pas tu vois ce que
je veux dire il écoule vite fait d'en
n'est pas dans les vidéos il est cool
mais en vrai ils nous parlent même pas
entre les prises quoi celle où par
contre l' iliden chercher où son
déclenchement séméga long auquel amis je
suis en train d'aller chercher à
l'oreille pour surprendre big three au
lit il attendait le poste depuis un
moment en bas je vais aller le chercher
et c'est lui qui va nous donner les mots
ok c'était tout le monde revue désolé on
est bon ok oh tu sais ce que je venais
de penser l'art peut pas me suis dit ils
nous préparent une surprise et même avec
ya l'air et qui arrive quoi aurait l'air
parti le mec il me donne le dit qu il
est reparti cette vidéo à la faire seule
en plaine c'est un honneur de vous
rencontrer
on s'est renseigné sur vous on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec la lucas et
ils viennent le dire en plus solide a
dit imaginer à l'arrêt mais les mecs
c'est chose faite je voulais vous mettre
bien aujourd'hui
merci à vous d'avoir alors je peux faire
tourner un peu plus sur toi sur ce que
tu fais mais voilà ça veut dire diriger
les monts si vous voulez des mots il y
en a
des millions on ne connaît pas tous
parce que j'avoue moi j'avoue je les
connais tous bon boulot c'est d'essayer
de refléter un petit peu ce qui se passe
à l'intérieur d'une société qui emploie
une langue comme le français et c'est
vachement compliqué parce que ça bouge
sans cesse au moins de 3000 mots
expressions essence nouveau tous les ans
donc il s'agit pas de choisir n'importe
quoi mais on choisit ce qui est le plus
courant franchement je trouve ça hyper
cool la langue de votre part devenu un
jeu et tout j'ai demandé à alain avant
de venir je vais donner une petite
mission à celle qui va choisir salins
qui a déjà sélectionné des mots pour
nous les gars je crie des mots simples
et compliqué à la fois un simple parce
qu'ils sont faciles à prononcer
compliqué parce que personne ne connaît
leur sens si j'en avais puisqu'il
connaît tous 5 mhz chacun pour chacun on
commence par huit premiers mots cubilot
cubilot je suis bi look
cb alors c'est quoi attendre cubilot qui
s'appelle à bulot moi je vois ça comme
une espèce de coquillages qui se voit ça
ok dit nous dit non à la france je suis
un guerrier aussi un fourneau fondre la
fonte
ok c'est pas un coquillage deuxième bon
épi soir à tanger une théorie je peux la
partager le pi soir c'est là on pisse
l'épicerie c'est là où on achète des
épices lépi soir c'est les piscines dans
laquelle on pisse
merci à tous c'est l'endroit où on met
les épices tout simplement nous à cannes
où elle allait même pas ça c'est le
poste qui est là ça vient du verbe épicé
avec deux aces épicé c'est quand on
assemble en marine tous les marins
connaissent vous avez deux gros câble il
faut obligatoirement l'ouvrir faire
sortir le petit taureau et associer les
taureaux les autres ok to soir c'est le
poisson dont on se sert pour séparer les
éléments à l'intérieur du câble pour
pouvoir les
mais les gars c'est la deuxième vidéo il
ya le challenge et bien il va pas nous
choisir des mots comme philosophie c'est
moche ebooks ebooks est un pokémon qui
avec déconne mon espèce de books a
évolué un chiche ebooks et en 3d
révolution c'est chiche ibuki [ __ ]
mais c'est presque j'y crois et alors la
vraie définition efficience et une pipe
orientale
charmarke fils et avec un grand tuyau
s'élancer en guinée selongey de la
chicha corps flaubert on parle beaucoup
quand il est à quand une envie je
l'avais lu ça j'avais lu je fume donc
monchy books a posé sur le mont ou
quatrième
ça c'est dur et pektas moi je dirais que
c'est une maladie corporelle seller
pektas je pensais quand tu branches
indien qui est situé prend 1 4 juin
c'est pire qu'une maladie c'est le fait
de passer l'heure ma gauche de crever en
[ __ ] ok cette vidéo est génial c'est
dans les vieux faut se méfier voyait les
12 hockey 5e moral à la mère de letat
merzlota ses prix ces prêts aux russes
pour vous diriger ma mère de l'auteur en
fait c'est dans la tradition russe comme
la mère poule tu vois c'est la cata vue
est vraiment une merde l'otan alors
c'est le sol quand il reste gelé toute
l'année en profondeur dans la tournoi
cela par contre si là pour le club si
les dieux hockey premiers mots pour big
lots un mot facile à mon avis vous allez
peut-être le connaître c'est cryptogames
c'est toute la gamme des crypto existe
cryptogames c'est tout simplement le
champignon a bien sûr c'est la famille
botanique dans lequel il ya notamment
les champignons alors deuxième os pour
conclure deuxièmement
évidemment compper kono et c'est tout ce
qui est tu voyais asinus miso vie de
machines
donc c'est qu'il ya une forme conique
alors c'est bien il a trouvé c'est
absolument ça alors là ça là je vais
dire il ya mille personnes qui viennent
d'acheter l'album moi vraiment à la con
la péter chine ont fait mine une péter
schep une péter schep c'est une tache
sur la peau qui ne correspond pas à une
cicatrice et il ya une blessure comme
tous les vieux mec comme moi alors 4e au
pur bijou à la dictature c'est le
clignement des yeux quand il est pas
contrôler ça va me flaud je le sens par
les instrus n'attend que toi rien à qui
doit être très très beau dans un rap ses
épis plots et puis plus au plomb au quai
jeunes anej sais même pas ce que c'est
et puis plomb battu tapez sur google
non vous aurez des images dégueulasse
oui c'est aussi dégueulasse a repris du
péritoine entre l'estomac et l'écolo
france verse hockey à moelle un bon jeu
maintenant mon féminin pourquoi l'ancien
qui est très gentil c'est la cupule moi
j'aime bien moi j'aime bien me suis
d'ailleurs mon coup mais est tout de
suite
reid hall alors la queue qls et le
quelques chants des moines d'accord ok
alors je sais que tu aimes les chiens
chihuahua deuxièmement le tronc millions
le trou millions c'est un petit insecte
c'est en fait c'est pas de sexe tonia
carrière c'est un piqueur d'accord
l'insecte piqueur de mes rêves quatrième
au la logopédie alors c'est quoi dis
nous c'est en fait à peu près la même
chose que leur taux phonie mais
hortefeux dit tout le monde connaît donc
la grille croquer dernier mot pour moi
catachrèse kathak que bois ou est une
figure de rhétorique c'est à dire que ça
ressemble à une comparaison ou une
métaphore une catachrèse pas mal ça je
maîtrise les métaphores et les cacas
crise alors les gars j'aimerais qu'on
propose un truc alors est ce que nous on
te donnerai pas 5
pour que toi tu fasses un slam à la
c'est quand tu veux je veux pas mourir
d'inanition d'inanition mais je veux tu
chies les filets avec mes rêves j'aime
pas trop les hipsters
je préfère ceux qui me disent oh mon
faitelles sens tel sens c'est peut-être
pas du freestyle mais je crois que ça
fera le job il a placé tous les mois la
foule est devenue la même veine yann à
l'intel sent vraiment que j'arrive pas à
croire ce cas merci à toi nom de toute
la communauté et leur communauté les
gens vont vraiment apprécier
on note avec plaisir déjà et inviteront
à la française à l'égard de l'idée on
n'est pas là il est parti à l'aller il
n'est pas sûr millwall qu'il allait
faire comme il adore of the mind bon les
amis c'est là on annonce une triste
nouvelle c'est que vous aurez pas d'un
couple est aujourd'hui appelée 3 mais
c'est pour votre bien parce qu'on va
faire un clip et sa central commun aux
huit heures ce sera pas un clip de
malades parce qu'on a que 24 heures pour
le faire finalement ils organisent et
bien demain rendez vous à 8 heures pour
le street clip freestyle à la reille
deux avertissements
[Musique]